last time we introduced pols and in
particular we introduced how to move
from the manipulation of feed-forward
and feedback systems and the geometric
sequence that fell out into using the
base of that geometric sequence to
attempt to predict the long-term
behavior of the system when we're
solving for poles and we're only
interested in long-term behavior one of
the easiest ways to do so is to solve
for the roots of Z where Z is a
substitution for 1 over R in the
denominator of the system function once
we've done that we have a list of poles
from that list of poles we would select
like to select the dominant pole or the
pole with the greatest magnitude and
then based on the magnitude and period
of that pole we can determine what the
long term behavior of our system looks
like today I'd like to mention to you
some notable things about poles if you
are interested in this information or
feedback in controls in the general
sense I highly recommend 6w3 but here's
some information you should at least be
aware of as a consequence of six at one
the other thing I'd like to do is just
walk through a couple of poll problems
to familiarize you or get you more
comfortable with the idea of solving for
the poles of a system function or
looking at the unit-sample response of a
system function and then graphing the
poles the first thing that I want to
mention is pole zero cancellation and
what do I mean when I say that I mean
that if both the numerator and the
denominator
have a degree of R in them then you're
gonna have both a zero and a pole if the
0 and the pole have the same value
associated with them you may be tempted
to cancel them out unless both the 0 and
the pole or equal to 0
don't do it the reason why is that when
you get to a implementation of a real
system it is highly unlikely that both
the 0 and the pole will be implemented
to a degree of accuracy that you will
actually see those two things cancel out
the only exception to this is when both
the pole and the zero are equal to 0 or
in this case
this you should feel free to convert to
this and almost any other situation
don't factor the other thing I want to
talk about is repeated roots
if you have a repeated root you'll have
repeated poles this does get tricky when
you're talking about how to add the unit
response of those poles but the long
term behavior of your system is going to
look the same so if both of these poles
are the dominant Pole then the
characteristics of both which are the
same are going to determine what your
long term behavior looks like if they're
not then the dominant pole is going to
determine what your long term behavior
looks like the last thing I want to
mention is superposition so far we've
only talked about the unit-sample
response of a system function and how we
use poles to determine what the long
term behavior of our system is going to
be we can look at the response to more
complicated more complicated inputs than
the unit-sample response or the Delta in
fact one of the things we'll probably
end up looking at at some point is the
step function the thing that you need to
know to go from talking about
unit-sample response to any other sort
of response is that we're still working
with an LTI system what that means is if
you take the summation of your inputs
apply the system function it is the same
and apply the system function to that
summation it is the same as the output
that would result from inputting all
those values at once
the best way I would like to explain it
is by referring again to
if your function was the system function
the same property applies now let's walk
through a poll problem here I have a
second-order system setup we've got two
degrees of our I have feedback and I can
solve for an expression of Y in terms of
X in fact let's do that right now why is
the result of the summation or a linear
combination of X plus a delayed signal
of Y scaled by one point six in a linear
combination with a scaled value of the
or a delayed value of the delayed value
of y scaled by negative 0.1 0.63 there's
my first degree
that's for consistency's sake there's my
second degree let's first solve for the
system function
if you're confused I recommend doing the
algebra from here to this expression you
should get this fraction out our second
step is to solve for the roots of Z
remember that Z is equal to one over arc
in the denominator of the system
function in this case we'll be working
with all I've done there is taken every
degree of our substituted in for one
over Z and then multiplied out so that
I'm not working with Z in the
denominator anymore I'm actually just
working with everything in the numerator
let me fold this back out I get this
expression and my poles are going to be
0.7 0.9 all right
based on my poles what are the
properties of the unit-sample response
in the long term first thing I'm going
to do is look for the dominant pole
among the poles that I found in this
case I don't even have to worry about
finding the length of the distance from
the origin for poles in the complex
plane all I have to worry about is the
magnitude of poles on the real axis 0.9
is my dominant pole because it's the
largest pole 0.9 is less than one so I'm
going to end up with convergence
eventually my system is going to
converge or tend towards zero the other
interesting property of my system is
what is this period and how does that
relate to what my function is going to
look like in this case we're only
working on the positive real axis so the
angle associated with graphing this pole
on the complex plane is zero so there is
no period for our system this means that
our system is going to converge
monotonically
now let's walk through some unit sample
responses and then graph through the
polls that generated those unit sample
responses on the unit circle where this
is the complex plane let's look at this
graph first the first thing that I
notice about this graph is that like in
the previous example we have monotonic
convergence we're tending towards zero
and we're not alternating or oscillating
about the x axis so I know I'm going to
be working somewhere along this line
before the edge of the unit circle
because at the edge of the unit circle
the distance from the origin is equal to
one if he made me guess then I would
look at the distance here and compare it
to the distance the next time step I
realize this is blackboard it's not
entirely to scale but for the purposes
of this demonstration I'd like to say
that the signal at this time step is 0.5
the signal from the tree previous time
step likewise at the next time step I
would like to say that this signal is
0.5 the signal from the previous time
step and so on and so forth therefore
I'm going to graph my pole right here
let's take a look at this graph I've
drawn these squiggles to indicate that
the unit-sample response exceeds the
bounds of the space that I gave for this
graph so just assume that these values
are much larger than I've drawn them the
first thing that I notice about this
human sample response graph is the fact
that not only am i increasing in a way
that does not seem to change in any way
right we're going to end up diverging is
that I'm actually alternating about the
x axis and then particularly that if I
were to call this an oscillation then I
would say it's an oscillation with
period 2 this means that I'm working
with a negative real pole the fact that
I'm diverging means that I'm working
with a negative real pole that is
greater than 1 or has magnitude greater
than 1 if you had to make the guess I
would look at the distance associated
with this time step compare it to the
distance associated with this time step
and if you had to ask me
I would say this is about 1.3 the value
at the previous time step likewise if I
were to look at the next time step I
would say that this increase is about 30
percent of the previous value I'm not
even gonna try that one but what I'm
trying to get at is that you can use
comparisons of previous and future time
steps in order to attempt to determine
the magnitude of your dominant pole if
you're working with a first-order system
if you're working with a second-order
system then it's possible that you'll
see some really interesting
initialization effects and you should
probably ask one of us you know what's
up but for this example we're gonna put
our pole over here here's the last graph
I want to talk about the first thing
that I noticed is that it doesn't seem
to be diverging but it doesn't really
seem to be converging either if this is
the case then I'm going to put it on the
unit circle the second thing that I
noticed is that it's not monotonic and
it's not alternating this is oscillating
so in order to determine what angle I'm
going to assign to my unit sample
response I'm going to count out the time
steps that it takes to cycle through an
entire period and then from there figure
out what the angle would have to be in
order to determine a period of that
length so if I start here I'm just going
to count one two three four five six
seven eight to complete one full
oscillation this means that my period is
eight if I have to divide 2 pi by a
particular angle in order to get out
eight I want to divide by PI over four
so at this point I'm working with a
magnitude of about one and I want this
angle to be about PI over four
this concludes my tutorial on solving
bolts
next time we'll end up talking about
circuits